korte the near-universal input method
for typing on computers tablets and
phones earth phones
wait y4v the keyboard itself used to be
the bottleneck not your typing speed and
typewriters were fragile machines just
pressing too closely situated letters
would jam the metal arms so QWERTY was
the solution to reduce jamming common
letter pairs were spread apart for tea
soon became standard and it never
changed because people so here we are
today with a layout design for
typewriters but don't give up hope my
friends we aren't necessarily stuck here
forever the solution is called Dvorak
Dvorak layout realized the plaza party
and solve for them the most common
letters are placed on the home row where
your fingers rest making typing faster
and easier the least common letters are
placed on the bottom row and are placed
to prevent awkward strokes
unfortunately Dvorak may never become
popular because of the network effect
even if you could instantly learn the
Dvorak layout it would have the
disadvantage of being uncommon you'd
have to switch to Cordy when using other
computers and playing WASD controlled
games would be a challenge so yeah
Cordy is probably here to stay